.
>>> EVERYTHING IS BOOKED.
>> THERE IS NOTHING TO CHICAGO?
>> NOTHING TO CHICAGO, NEW YORK,
NASHVILLE, YOU NAME IT.
EVERYTHING'S GONE.
>> WHAT ABOUT A PRIVATE PLANE?
>> A PRIVATE PLANE FROM PARIS TO
CHICAGO WOULD BE OUT OF THE
BUDGET FOR, WELL, ALMOST
EVERYONE.
BUT KATE McCALLISTER IN "HOME
ALONE" SEEMED WILLING BEAR THE
COST TO GET HOME TO SEE KEVIN
HER SON, OF COURSE.
FANS OF THE CHRISTMAS CLASSIC
"HOME ALONE" HAVE WONDERED SO
MUCH MONEY DID THE McCALLISTERS
ACTUALLY HAVE?
WELL, YOU'RE LUCKY.
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" CRUNCHED
THE NUMBERS WITH ECONOMISTS AND
GOT SOME ANSWERS.
OF COURSE, PHIL IS AT THE MAGIC
WALL TO BREAK IT ALL DOWN.
NOT POOR.
>> NOT POOR, NO.
THIS IS THE MOST PRESSING
QUESTION OF THE HOLIDAY SEASON.
I DON'T THINK THERE IS ANY
QUESTION ABOUT IT.
JUST HOW MUCH MONEY DID THE
McCALLISTER FAMILY HAVE?
THIS IS WHY GREAT REPORTING
MATTERS.
A HUGE HAT TIP TO "THE NEW YORK
TIMES" FOR A GREAT STORY.
LET'S START WITH THE FAMILY
HOME.
THE McCALLISTERS LIVED IN A
WEALTHY CHICAGO SUBURB, A HOME
BY 1990 STANDARDS WOULD HAVE
BEEN AFFORDABLE BY CHICAGO'S 1%.
ZILLOW'S CURRENT ESTIMATED VALUE
FOR THIS PROPERTY AN EYE-POPPING
$2.4 MILLION.
WHICH AS THE "TIMES" POINTS OUT
THE BEST CLUE TO THE FAMILY'S
NET WORTH.
TWO WORDS TO MIND.
SILVER TUNE-UP.
>> THAT'S THE ONE, MARVIN.
THAT'S THE SILVER TUNA.
>> VERY G.
>> IT'S LOADED.
IT'S GOT LOTS OF TOP FLIGHT
GOODS.
STEREOS, VCRs.
>> TOYS?
>> PROBABLY LOOKING AT SOME FINE
JEWELRY.
POSSIBLE CASH HOARD.
ODD MARKETABLE SECURITIES.
WHO KNOWS?
>> SO "THE TIMES" ASKED
ECONOMISTS IN THE FEDERAL
RESERVE HOW MUCH WOULD THE
McCALLISTERS HAVE TO EARNING TO
LIVE IN A HOME LIKE THAT?
THEIR ANSWER WORKING UNDER THE
ASSUMPTION THEY SPENT IT NO MORE
THAN THE RECOMMENDED 30% ON
THEIR HOUSING, THEY WOULD HAVE
TO RING IN $300,000 IN 1990, OR
CLOSE TO $700,000 IN 2023, AND
TODAY'S MARKET WOULD HAVE TO BE
MAKING MORE THAN THAT TO BE ABLE
TO AFFORD THAT HOME.
BUT, OBVIOUSLY, THERE IS A
CRITICAL QUESTION HERE.
WHERE DID THE MONEY ACTUALLY
COME FROM?
TIME TO DIG IN.
SIMPLE ANSWER.
WE DON'T KNOW.
THE MOVIE NEVER EXPLAINS.
BUT FANS HAVE THEORIES.
ONE CLUE THEY POINT TO, THERE
ARE MULTIPLE MANNEQUINS
SCATTERED THROUGHOUT THE HOUSE.
THAT SEEMS RARE, YOU WOULD
THINK.
LED SOME TO BELIEVE THAT KEVIN'S
MOM COULD HAVE BEEN A FASHION
DESIGNER, A CAREER THEY WENT
WITH IN THE OFFICIAL MOVIE.
SO WE THINK WE PUT A CHECKMARK
BY THAT.
THE "TIMES" SPOKE TO THE AUTHOR
WHO SAID HE MADE KEVIN'S DAD A
BUSINESSMAN BECAUSE IT WAS A
SAFE BET.
THE UNCLES, UNCLE FRANK, TRAVELS
WITH THE FAMILY TO PARIS.
NOT A BEACON OF GENEROSITY.
>> HEY, PIZZA'S HERE.
>> THAT'S 122.50.
>> IT'S MY BROTHER'S HOUSE.
HE'LL TAKE CARE OF IT.
>> OF COURSE, THERE IS UNCLE
ROB.
HE PAYS FOR THE WHOLE FAMILY,
15, TO FLY 30 PARIS TO SPEND THE
HOLIDAY WITH HIS FAMILY, FOUR
FIRST CLASS TICKETS FOR BROTHERS
AND THEIR WIVES OPENING UP HIS
APARTMENT, IT HAS EIFFEL TOWER
VIEWS TO HOST THEM ALL.
THIS WHILE MAINTAINING AS WE
LEARN IN THE SEQUEL THE UPPER
WEST SIDE BROWNSTONE THAT KEVIN
ENDS UP VISITING IN "HOME ALONE"
2.
ONE OTHER THEORY, ORGANIZED
CRIME.
THIS IS SPECULATION.
WE DON'T KNOW THIS SPECIFICALLY.
BUT FANS SAY McCALLISTERS' HOME
MAY HAVE BEEN TARGETED AS A MOP
VENDETTA, KEVIN'S VIOLENCE AS
EVIDENCE, A CHILD EXPOSED TO
CRIMINAL ACTIVITY.
"THE TIMES" WAS NOT ABLE TO RULE
THIS OUT.
ER NEITHER HAVE MY SOURCES WE
WILL CONTINUE TO PRESS FOR THOSE
ANSWERS.
IN THE MEANTIME, ONE PLAYER
DIRECTLY INVOLVED IN THIS
PROCESS DID GO ON THE RECORD
WITH A VERY IMPORTANT POINT.
QUOTE, TO ME WITH RESPECT TO THE
FANS WHO ARGUE IF THE PARENTS'
INCOME OR HOUSE COST SHOULD
INSTEAD SIMPLY ENJOY THE MOVIE.
THAT WAS FROM THE SET DIRECTOR.
GOOD ADVICE.
>> THAT IS EVERYTHING FOR ME
THIS CHRISTMAS.
>> WHAT IS BETTER, "HOME ALONE"
1, 2?
THERE IS A 4 ARKS APPARENTLY.
>> WE WATCHED 2 LAST NIGHT WITH
THE KIDS.
THEY LOOKED THE NEW YORK
CONNECTION NOW THAT THEY HAVE --
GO TO NEW YORK SOMETIMES.
"HOME ALONE," A CLASSIC, MAN.
>> LUCA, MY 5-YEAR-OLD, BUILDS
BOOBY TRAPS ALL OVER THE HOUSE
THAT I MAY OR MAY NOT TRIP ON
ALL THE TIME.
SO THANKS TO THIS MAV.
>> THAT'S A GREAT KID.
>>> THE TONG THE 12 DAYS A
CHRISTMAS A HOLIDAY STAPLE.
>> ON THE FOURTH DAY OF
CHRISTMAS MY TRUE LOVE SENT TO
ME ♪
♪ FOUR CALLING PIRDS.
>> THREE FRENCH HENS.
>> TWO TURTLE DOVES.
>> AND A PARTRIDGE IN A PEAR
TREE ♪♪
>> OF COURSE THE PARTRIDGE IN A
PEAR TREE.
HAVE YOU EVER STOPPED TO THINK
WHAT THOSE GIFTS WOULD LOOK LIKE
UNDER YOUR TREE.
FIVE GOLDEN RINGS, SEVEN SWANS
A-SWIMMING, TEN LORDS-A-LEAPING.
HAS TO BE EXPENSIVE.
ANDY BERNARD FROM "THE OFFICE"
LEARNED THAT THE HARD WAY.
>> WHOEVER IS GIVING ME THE 12
DAYS OF CHRISTMAS AS MY SECRET
SANTA, PLEASE STOP.
I CAN'T TAKE IT ANYMORE.
>> IT'S A GIFT.
>> I BEGGED DWIGHT AND JIM TO
GIVE ME AARON FOR SECRET SANTA
AND I DECIDED TO GIVE ERIN THE
12 DAYS OF CHRISTMAS.
>> IS IT MY FAULT THE FIRST DAYS
ARE BASICALLY 30 BIRDS?
>> RICHARD QUEST HAS THE NUMBERS
ON HOW MUCH THIS WOULD ALL COST.
RICHARD, THIS MAY BE MY FAVORITE
CONVERSATION WITH YOU OF THE
YEAR.
SO TAKE IT AWAY.
>> TWO TURTLE DOVES AND A
PARTRIDGE IN A PEAR TREE.
HOW MUCH WOULD ALL THIS LOT
COST?
WELL, YOU'VE GOT TO WORK IT OUT.
FIVE GOLDEN RINGS.
THEY BASICALLY HAVEN'T CHANGED
IN PRICE.
THE THREE BIG ONES, SHALL TURTLE
DOVES, WHICH ARE UP 25% BECAUSE
OF THE RARITY OF TURTLE DOVES.
NUMBER TWO, PARTRIDGE IN A PEAR
TREE.
THAT'S A 14%.
WHY?
THE PARTRIDGE HAS TO LIVE IN A
PEAR TREE.
THE RENT ON THE PEAR TREE UP
14%.
AND THE THIRD MOST EXPENSIVE,
THE GEESE LAYING.
♪ FIVE GOLD RINGS ♪♪
>> THOSE SIX GEESE-A-LAYING ARE
8% BECAUSE THEY ARE RARE, YOU
CANNOT GET YOUR HANDS ON GEESE
AT THE MOMENT.
PUT IT ALL TOGETHER.
IF YOU BUY THE 12 DAYS OF
CHRISTMAS, COME ON TOGETHER.
♪ FIVE GOLD RINGS ♪
>> PUT IT TOGETHER, $46,730.
UP 2.7%.
PNC BANK HAVE BEEN DOING THIS
FOR 40 PLUS YEARS.
>> RICHARD, I KNOW YOU WANT US
TO SING THE FIVE GOLDEN RINGS.
♪ GOLDEN RINGS ♪
>> PHIL, DO NOT LEAVE ME HANGING
HERE.
>> I AM INTIMIDATED BY RICHARD'S
TALENT AND ALSO VERY SURE
RICHARD COULD GET A HOLD OF THE
GEESE IF HE WANTED TO.
THAT'S HIS THING.
>> SO --
>> GO AHEAD.
>> THE NUMBER ONE QUESTION.
REMEMBER, YOU HAVE TO BUY THE
ITEMS AGAIN AND AGAIN.
♪ FIVE GOLD RINGS ♪
>> YOU HAVE TO BUY THEM AGAIN
AND AGAIN AND AGAIN.
SO THE TOTAL COST OF CHRISTMAS,
346, 201,972.
THAT'S A GAIN OF 2.5%.
COME ON, STAND BY.
YOU CAN DO THIS.
♪'D MAIDS-A-MILKING ♪
♪ FIVE GOLDEN RINGS ♪♪
>> THERE IT IS.
>> HE WON'T DO IT.
>> RICHARD QUEST, YOU ARE MY
FAVORITE.
THANK YOU, MY FRIEND.
>> THANK YOU.
HAPPY CHRISTMAS.
>> YOU MAY HAVE SO